Tina is a country famous for three
things,
tango,
soccer and economic crises.
Although that latter one might change
sooner rather than later.
Yes.
Dvo once again,
we aren't talking about lithium or white
gold or the new oil and it's the staff
that have batteries are made out of
lithium is what powers your smart phone,
your laptop and maybe even your electric
car.
As we said in this other video.
Argentina is alongside with Chile and
Bolivia,
one of the three countries that make up
this so called lithium triangle.
This is an area where 60 to 80% of the
welds discovered lithium reserves are
concentrated from these three countries.
Argentina is getting the biggest
detention like international investors.
Yup.
That writes the biggest hedge funds have
their eyes on this country.
This is a big surprise given the dodge
and Tina used to be the boogie man of
finances.
The problem childs of economics now,
well,
it's growing into something of a
rockstar.
Sorry.
Today's question is,
well,
what happens to this country in which
improve their image in assumption,
short time?
Can they really become the leader over
the lithium race is most important of
all?
Can Lithium turn Argentina into a new
Abu Darby today?
We all goings on.
So all of these questions,
but before we get started,
let's take a look at the history.
Argentina first.
In the last few years,
Argentina had become something of a
boogie man,
but hedge funds under the presidency of
Cristina Fernandez de catch.
Now Argentina's governance did it.
Whatever they could to scare away any
foreign company you might want to invest
in the
treat tobacco.
Of course it [inaudible]
when it comes to the mining and oil
industry.
Kirschner made an interesting move.
In 2008 she passed a law against the
repatriation of capital.
This means that if an Australian mining
company made profit by extracting oil
and minerals on Argentinian soil,
the government wouldn't allow the
company to send that money back to
Australia.
Coach's goal was to force these foreign
companies to keep the financial benefits
of their mining in the country
math or the last.
As you can imagine,
the consequence of this law was that
most of the foreign companies simply
stops doing business in the country.
The ends of the day.
I mean,
why would they,
if it was forbidden to enjoy those
profits at home?
Well,
this,
it was not enough.
The real turning point for Argentina
came in the year 2012
Argentina,
x rates ypf to rub salt
repsol all of the largest oil company in
Spain in the year 1998 and merged with
Arjun time company Y F for many years,
this brands was simply called at Repsol
Ypf.
But one day,
Cristina Fernandez de Koechner in a very
Donald Trump fashion sense,
well,
Argentina first Hashtag make Argentina
grades again.
He lets him a key.
How does that stay here?
Even if their shareholders are
foreigners are Argentinian competence.
Now you might wonder,
well,
what happens next?
Well,
of course the repsol pursued several
lawsuits with the governments of
Argentina,
but this was not the worst thing.
The biggest problem was that after being
nationalized Argentine YDF,
it reduced their oil production.
Oh,
wheel production extends decline as rig
activity slows.
Yeah.
Listen,
I know what you're thinking.
You're probably thinking,
well,
what's the connection between oil
production and it's being owned by
private companies or being owned by the
governments?
I mean there are several states,
oil companies that work really well.
For one example there is Aramco.
This is the biggest dinosaur juice
producer.
I'm still,
it is.
I'm buying the Saudi government's.
The problem here is that both in the oil
ams,
the mining industry,
you need high tech.
Yeah.
Each company has different technologies
and patents.
In other words,
when why the f wants it to drill those
oil beds of Baca.
I'm wet and they needed to utilize a
complicated technology called fracking.
I am as well only a few companies in the
wells that have the machines and the
skills to do this kind of work.
This is why it is so common.
The difference.
Oil companies create a joint venture to
exploit an oil bat when reps old left
Argentina,
why p have lost a technology partner and
this is why people will say the catch
near fought against those Spanish near
Liberals and ended up partnering with
the American ones.
Sure.
YPF signed one point $5 billion shale
oil deal.
Hold on just a second because,
well,
this isn't the end of our story.
The biggest issue here is what happens
when you take over a company from one
day to the other.
Well,
what happens is the rest of the
businesses are going to be afraid of you
and good luck trying to convince them to
invest in your country.
Think about it.
Let's imagine you have an oil or a
mining company.
Would you really dead set up a factory
and the loss of facilities in a place
where the government can just sees all
of that from you.
I think not man's this among other
factors.
This is what explains why Argentina
today has such a big crisis,
but now Argentina has a president called
Maury,
Theo Macri man's well,
the times they are a changing.
Okay.
Gold rush in Argentina and December,
2015 macri took his place in the pink
house.
The Pink House is the elgin time version
of the White House.
That was the country I'm
tree in the middle of a bankruptcy.
Real inflation was higher than 40%
dollars were sold on the black market
and there was no company willing to
invest in the country.
And all of this was despite them being
one of the wealthiest countries when it
comes to natural resources.
This is why since the very first moment,
Macri has tried to conduct a 180 degree
shift compared to what his predessessors
yeah.
Yeah.
Argentina's new government scraps,
mining taxes.
In other words,
Macri knows that lithium is a pls
opportunity to repair the accounting
books.
Of course not.
No one expects Argentine.
And to become a new Dubai over night
that this white gold is a windfall and
that money could cover the gaps of
Argentina's budget without raising taxes
and without cutting costs.
And as well,
this explains laws like this,
Margie,
Tina signs,
mining deal to unified regulations
attract investment.
In other words from now on,
mining multinationals have an open door
to the country and unlike what happens
with the coach and the era of these
foreign companies can do whatever they
want with their profits.
This is happening because Macri has
removed the anti repatriation law as if
this was not enough.
Legislation has been put into facts
which unifies mining regulations all
across the country.
This means that the rules are the same
no matter where the lithium battery is.
Further,
the mining companies will not have to
pay any special mining tax in.
Yeah,
industry heavyweights album Marlay court
saw Clinica,
he manera de Chile s a era met s a n
junk.
See Gum fun lithium company are among
groups looking at expanding or building
new lithium operations
in Argentina.
Pause.
Hold on for just a second because well,
things they are not quite as great as
they seem.
Lithium is a great opportunity for
Argentina bars.
As you know,
having natural resources does not mean
your country isn't necessarily wealthy.
Many entre into Indians fear what they
would call a new Potosi.
This means is that they fear that their
country would become flooded with
foreign companies that take the
resources and leave without bringing any
money in to Argentina.
So the question now becomes what can
Argentina do to avoid such a
catastrophe?
Yeah,
really
chance of origin.
Tina
said in a previous video,
the real business of lithium is not
lithium itself,
but to the added value products you can
manufacture.
Yeah.
With us at the time
when we recorded this video,
a metric ton of lithium had a market
price of $9,000 nevertheless,
if we take that raw material and then we
turned it into mobile phone batteries,
we could get an income of between 1.5
and $5 million.
Of course,
this is a very rough estimation,
but it does help us understand something
important.
Hold on just a moment because this is
still mode as simple as it looks,
works
muscle lithium battery factories are in
countries like the United States,
Germany,
or of course China.
These three countries have worldclass
network of small companies provide
services and components to the big
manufacturing.
Yeah,
well we're talking to
about logistics,
semiconductors and someone.
All of these things make the
manufacturing process cheaper and more
efficient,
but not only that,
this network effect is what attracts the
best engineers in skilled professionals
to these countries.
This is a central,
if you want to create a high tech
industry in it
country,
like good luck trying to convince a
woman who lives in San Francisco and
makes a six figure salary to move to
Roserio Argentina to work in a factory.
As you can imagine,
that's pretty much impossible.
Now you might be wondering,
Wash,
can matt green due to industrialize his
country?
Well,
the first thing we have to keep in mind
is that silicon valley,
it was not created in a day.
Nevertheless,
Argentina has a great advantage over
California.
They can make easy money by selling raw
lithium.
Of course there's money can be used by
the government to simply boost their
earnings,
but it is also a good opportunity to
invest in universities that will train
those workers that might start those
small companies that are needed in order
to get the big factories up and yeah,
running
the government can also co-financed
brand new businesses.
This is actually the formula that helps
Israel become a technological capital as
well.
So far it seems that Macri is committed
to working this way.
We have learned,
we have understand that in addition to
our talents,
our huge natural resources,
we have to add constancy.
We have to add rule of law to be
predictable.
But
wait a minute because there are some
dark clouds on the horizon.
All these opportunities,
Argentina has will disappear if my cree
or whoever follows him falls back into
the temptation of destroying the rule of
law and going back to ultra nationalism,
which could scare away foreigners as it
has in many other countries.
And it seems that Cristina Fernandez de
catch now wants to run for office again.
I am not asking you to vote for me.
[inaudible] I'm not asking you to vote
with the people behind me.
I am asking you to vote for yourself.
Okay.
Say well now it's your turn.
Do you think Argentina could restore the
rule of Lauren's to come a wealthy
country thanks to lithium or how are we
going to see a new nationalist backlash
and there's a brand new economic crisis?
Well you can leave your answer in the
comment section below and just before he
goes to there you've got an important
request from you.
You might have noticed that we rather
like using rock music in our videos and
we'd love to hear from anyone who has a
Benz and thinks that their music could
be a good fit for us.
We will of course give credit to any
music that we do use in a video.
If you are interested in this,
do you drop us an email?
That's info,
adds a visual politic.net also,
do not forget to check out our friends
at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that are not mine.
And if you liked this video,
give it a thumbs up and subscribe.
And as I'll see
you next time,
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com
slash podcast see you there.